josé garcimore les messins d'ailleurs
été depuis rosato et bien nous avons
pour cette avant dernière émission de
l'année 119 une brochette tout à fait
exceptionnel je crois que parlons
franchement c'est le chili oui c'est ça
c'est l'excellent élite même de la
profession que nous avons réunis autour
de nous disons les comédiens les plus
brillants de leur génération de
plusieurs générations s'est jamais le
ménage on avoue michel serrault jean
poiret pour le film de pierre china la
gueule de l'autre bertrand blier qui va
nous parler du film buffet froid ses
côtés gérard depardieu qui est à
l'affiché de ce film pierre tchernia qui
est ici chez lui il connaît mieux un
instrument mois encore notre ami bernard
blier qui est venu encourager son fils
c'est ça non non non j'ai vu ce que
j'aime bien avec mes petits camarades
oui mais en fait on n'a pas souvent
l'occasion de vous voir avec votre fils
sur le plateau et télévision c'est assez
rare d'être content de lui
oui je suis très fier bon andrea parisy
qui a alors le privilège davantage
d'être l'épousé de michel serrault dans
le film la gueule de l'autre est à la
fois du merris l'automne
oui oui elle a du mérite aussi pourquoi
oui justin vu le film va raconter et
jean carmet qui complètent la
distribution de la buffet froid et
michel tu sais quand même aux témoins
doute c'est quand même l'assemblage le
plus misogyne de l'année nous oui
j'aimerais même une femme pour un bébé
j'aurais souhaité que je ne vienne pas
je veux partager ses vues sont hélas pas
pu être là cet après midi c'est dommage
ça dommage
dites moi vous ne m'en voulez pas si je
commence à parler du film de bertrand
blier
moi personnellement absolument pas alors
on a tout de suite parlé de buffet froid
vous allez vous avez tout de suite nous
parler de ce film parce que c'est
difficile de raconter déjà un film c'est
pas pire china qui me dira le contraire
lui qui parle de cinéma toutes les
semaines également sur tout c'est un
film où l'atmosphère compte beaucoup
alors comment peut-on en quelques mots
dire aux spectateurs qui nous regarde ce
qu'est buffet froid il ya déjà un point
commun entre les deux films dont il va
être question cet après midi c'est
l'humour mais votre humour avoue peut
être à nouveau plus froid plus noir que
l'on rentre non oui disons que c'est une
liste c'est un film irracontable mais on
ce qu'on peut en dire c'est que c'est un
film sur la trouille et que tous les
personnages du film
surtout le petit trio des constitué par
mon père jean gérard ce sont des gens
qui ont là qu'ils ont tellement la
trouille que final ils ont peur de tout
son coeur de même ils ont peur de la
solitude et ont peur qu'on vienne les
déranger dans cette solitude ont peur
des portes qui grincent ils ont peur
d'un plongeon qui sue qui soudent de
leur ombre
et finalement ils ont tellement peur que
le pli finisse par déclencher des
successions de refroidissement
parlons des rôles de chacun est ce que
c'est car mais le plus la fpt sûrement
dans la fiction vous êtes à montaner
chacun connaît mon courage d'aller sur
le site en ce qui concerne l'or car mais
fait une fixation sur les femmes seules
sa part une composition en réalité votre
votre père d'un art blier est un
policier pas comme les autres c'est un
inspecteur de police très bien habillée
très élégant sommes toujours comme
surnom qui simplement lorsqu'il assiste
à un meurtre en passe de changer de
trottoir et qui déteste la nature mais
ça on n'y reviendra plus tard oui gérard
depardieu chômeurs chômeurs toujours oui
c'est à dire que c'est un joueur qui
sait même plus il a travaillé un jour
c'est quelqu'un qui sait quelqu'un qui
était normal qui marche qui déambule et
puis qui
des causes qui fait des cauchemars
épouvantable des rêves qui rêve qu'il
est poursuivi par la police pour meurtre
alors il ya un environnement particulier
vous avez tourné dans la défense bon
c'est pas par hasard
adam détour vide tous nos points forts
la défense la tour mais en fin d'année
travail c'est ça c'est pareil pourquoi
sa part non pas parce que l'action se
situe dans une tour de 30 étages dans
laquelle il a un look est un soldat
quatrième gérant et arrive un jour un
2ème locataire qui est l'inspecteur de
police
et forcément en bon voisin ils font
connaissance
eh bien on va voir non pas un extrême et
plusieurs extraits puisque vous avez eu
la gentillesse de nous faire un montage
on verra un autre extrait tout à l'heure
qui donne une autre idée de ce film donc
un montage de buffet froid avec donc
d'un art billets jean carmet genre
depardieu geneviève page également
denise gence bien d'autres acteurs
excellents voici ce montage